It all started with a picture and a Facebook page.
I put Karrie's picture on Facebook, the first day of school,...
...and I came home from work that day and had a ton of e-mails from parents of kids,...
...daughters with Down syndrome who said, "Where do you get her clothes?"
That's where Wet Seal comes in.
See, this is Karrie's favorite store,...
...so Sue set up a Facebook page with Karrie wearing a different outfit from here every day.
Because she wants to be a model for Wet Seal,...
...maybe this will work.
Maybe we can catch their attention this way.
You might say she caught their attention.
They said if she can get 10,000 likes by 5:00 on Friday,...
...that they would have a surprise for her.
She had over 11,000 by noon on Thursday.
The surprise?
Wet Seal flew Karrie and her mom to California for a photo shoot.
She kinda comes to life when the camera's on her.
To watch Karrie, you'd never believe that when she was born,...
...I was told by this geneticist when she was a week old to never expect anything from her.
Sue never bought into that.
There's a level of expectation that we all do our best where it concerns her.
And that's what got Karrie where she's going.
Well, that and a lot of personality.
Bunny ears on Mom?
In Collinsville, Steve Harris, News 4.